footings are all the students that
hearing us it says something different
that what you study until now it's a
different way of computing different
type of architecture which is very
useful for a machine learning so that
we'll talk today with agenda we'll start
with with introduction to associative a
processing we see some useless example
such a similarity search a large-scale I
attention computing for a for a NLP a
few short one short learning based on
associative computing we show some of
the software model which is based on the
turns of flow in some future future ok
so what we say that matrix
multiplication is not enough so actually
all what we know today the gpgpu try to
improve the matrix multiplication but
that we know when if you look on the
next iteration a new type of a machine
learning algorithm we see that we need
high precision floating point operation
we need to support a multi-position from
one bit to bit for bit etcetera for for
inference for real-time inference we
have to do some linearity scalar for big
data we want to add want you to chip
more cheap mobile together we want a
nearly linear scale we have some
functions that are serial operations
that cannot run in parallel with support
for example top K recommendation speech
recognition classification and also
heavy computation such as non-linearity
a exponent for example in softmax and of
course we have to support it is been
been wet it been do a bandwidths to get
high speed in a low power ok let's start
from the 80s in the 80s this is the von
Neumann architecture we know that there
is a memory there the CPU just the CP
the memory is a dense
but slower in the CPU is just a logic
and in the butt run runs faster then
when based on the growth of of of
Morelos a CPU become become faster in
order to to support this or to support
the bandwidths people start adding more
and more memory inside the CPU the cache
this is about the 90s for example but in
the - 2006 there was a very very high
very inefficient way to increase the
frequency so things become flattening
and but more slows a number of
transistors that we can we can put in a
chip hence it can continue to to
increase so in this point we start
talking on parallel computing at two
cores at the same at the same CPU
talking to a memory but there is but
there there is a okay so here okay well
we have to put some local in global
memory not not just a local man we have
to add local and global memory to
support to support a the bandwidth but
as we can see here is that memory
becomes is a larger part of the chip we
continue to add more and more memory on
top of a of a logic now even in GP GPUs
who have durham who have caches we still
have we still have a memory so we have
very high power larger size expensive so
what next so this is a von Neumann this
is a von Neumann architecture so what's
next
and they took from one of this time for
presentation as we can see here that the
power consumption to bring data from the
memory to the CPU is orders magnitude
higher than compute inside memory
so now I'm going to show you how we
change the roles memory as we know
traditional memory as we know are much
smarter than we think we can do a lot in
standard conventional memory it's a not
a special memory it's not the other type
of memory it's standard standard memory
it's not a quantum memory it's a
standard memory that you see how smart
is a memory and what we can do with the
memory so with APU which call it
associative processing unit that we will
see as you can see here there is a
memory which is the memory and compute
are in the same die connected connect
together the Threepio and the memory are
connecting together it's the same and
there is a simple view see how it's
wrong what exactly what we mean when we
say compute computing memory it's not
the memory and Sen and processor in the
same in the same chip is a memory as a
processing is the same when I say the
same this means that the instruction it
just read and write
there is no addition or multiplication
with read and write we can do addition
with read and write we can do
multiplication just to instruction right
instruction and right instruction that's
it
this is the microcode now we'll see how
how its work as we see here this is
again volume and computing what is a
computer computer is what is lu lu is
just a machine with logic that has to
read deleted from the memory one row at
a time
one others at the time and 20 states
there is a logic remove chinese state
this is a computer the Lu has to change
the state of the memory has to read the
data from the memory change state and
write it back changing state so can we
achieve can we change the state take the
memory this is 80 years people what they
do is just change state in the mirror
so there is a different way to change
the state not just bring the data to
tell you yes the conventional memory has
the ability to change state during the
read and write operation you will see
now suppose this is a memory this is a
memory with dead I want to change the
state without CPU just with readwrite I
want to do an operation without
connecting to the CPU just to the memory
what is the trick very simple
instead of actions one row at a time
I artist multiple row many two three
four ten thousand reasonable and many
for right so what what I'll get here
this is a bit line I know that I can
read the bit line but if on this bit
line
I just charge zero and one many zero one
I get something merge all of this
function but no this is not emerging
this is just a simple operation
so the memory as it's built today over
the last eight years his ability to do
no repression during the bit line so
what we see here the memo is a memory is
a bit line the bit lines itself are
changing the state during the read and
write the bit line the wire the wire is
a gate the wire of the memo is the gate
the data is the data and the War of the
gate so if it's a gate if we change
state in the memory why we have to write
it to the CPU why just not keep it here
so advocacy hew standard memory on the
grid line satisfied Moore's law because
we have a sister
if we have a system that can be Noren
and it satisfied the Morgan law so this
meant that we can do any type of
fraction addition multiplication
floating-point similarity search CN n DN
n all inside a memory because we satisfy
the Morgan loop example now let's see
just a we'll just run them to stable I
have ABC as input the output we have to
implement this by a gate you know this
is Colonel table we know this with a
gate which is a logic function with a
car no not a not b plus BC but this is
equal it put not not it's say I get not
not a not C so this is the function
which is as you can see here this is an
N of NAND so in memory can do nor on an
orange is the same if you define zero as
a high and one is low it's an N so then
nor is the same so we have meant of Ned
here so what we do here we do just wait
wait read and write read to input a note
and see not and write to some temporary
different cell in the memory here we
open this two-bit line a two-word line
and write to teach you and then with
combines then another we just read t1
and t2 and write it invited to the
destination so also so if you have
because it's a memory it's not like a
CPU oh it's just bit like if you have
ten million of that 20 millions at 1
billion which technical clocks to do
that because it's a memory so every bit
line now become a process or a process
of that can do floating-point 16-bit in
one handling while in LT clocks but if
we really know that forget those beta
operations so every midterm takes one
o'clock so memory traditional memory is
a Kavanagh table a machine parallel car
notable machine traditional memories
standard memory don't have to design
just change this others controller with
the way that you can read and write
multiple row at the same time so it's
actually as you can see a different type
of computing it's not a CPU that just
bring the data by the CPU just control
tell the memory just I want to do the
matrix multiplication is a and well it
really does tell me that what the CPU is
doing here another example suppose we
have the 8 bit 8 vector a 32 million
number I want to add with another 32
million numbers or sitting in standard
memory I looked on all I hoped I
implement the truth tables food either
truth tables take four clocks so I go I
I'm doing the truth table of the list if
every every bit slice at the time so
it's take four clocks four beats lies
so it takes 32 clocks to do this
addition in 532 million divided if it's
32 clock divided by 32 millions and run
the membrane one gigahertz here just
simple examples that we can get 1 beta
ops easily in the Des Moines ok this is
just the beginning this is just warming
up we can do much more in the memory
they just so sure you float better we
can do logic we can do more than memory
here we go
now in we know that in deep learning we
want to do addition with application we
want to do in memory to set bandwidth
but there's many many cases that we want
to do search there is similarity search
and exact search we want to do search we
have a pattern and we have to look to
Northern all the memory as we say that
we want to do some Teresa we want we
don't want to add another memory another
memory a to that so if I have for
example here a key here he 0 1 1 0 and I
want to search to search it here in the
memory so he was the 1 1 so I want to
search so again this is traditional
memory so what we do here we just
duplicating the data one line in one
o'clock so if it's probably like four
o'clock we duplicate duplicate with
inverse we duplicate with inverse the
key now all places where there is
someone in the key opens reasonable and
if and this guy looked only zero in its
nor operation its get one and here is
get zero so it's match so just again the
key just opens a bit line is open
sorry but it is open there's a the word
line just multiple reasonable that what
we do okay but some time we want to we
have some cases that we have don't care
0 1 and don't care and we want to search
this 0 1 1 0 here so here they don't
care don't care so I want that I want a
tag here and tag here to say that I
found this one this guy so what is the
trick here what we do here first of all
we put 0 here and put the data except
duplicate again the key opens reasonable
get one anyone so okay now what we can
see that when we have a memory itself we
know that it's a bit if it to bit it's a
two bit and also one input nor gate and
one tecum gate if we take three it can
distribute the three input nor gate two
input so we have all this we all this
type of this type combination and and
there's no limit to how we can define it
so there is a lot of room here for to do
a lot of research how we can do more in
the memory that here okay
now what we can summarize this part is
that we can looked on all bit line every
bit line is a different number as a
vector we call it vector a and vector B
we can do C we can if you can do a
normal run and operation it's depend on
number of clock but we can implement any
function we call it between alien be
what else we can do is a chip actually
they were going to be a chip that it's
not just science fiction it's going to
have a chip by tapping out in in few
months it's going to be a product say
mid mid next year with this associative
agent so we have in the chipper
capability to move section back and
forth before doing the operation in this
give us the ability to do never the
Pershing's our example convolutional see
FFT etc if we combine compute and and
the exact search we have for example we
have a database we search as this twenty
we found that there are three we can
count them inside and there's a lot of
applications for searching count like
random forest nearest neighbor already
so many find many many application in
any application together now if we
compare ear this is a logarithmic scale
in this in a linear scale so here is
this is a ap use associative this is the
GPU this is the FPGA and this is the CPU
so the different other pieces this is an
FPGA sorry this is this is the GPGPU
right now the GPU and single chip can
support them eight teraflops and running
in a small chip with support 1.6
teraflop so we are we are about the same
order of magnitude as they as a GPU
actually the GPU starting from graphic
processor so they push the matrix
multiplication we all started we are a
memory company we were memory company
and we started from memory and we we we
move from memory to compute so so our
background is a memory to bring to do so
we are pushing in this direction and the
GPU to you push into this direction but
we have also solutions for that because
in right now in in teraflops per that we
are more than 100 Giga frost profit
which is better than better than the
GPGPU but actually this not this not
this is not so important because it is
we have the multi precision topic I
search later on you will see a soft max
non-linearity scalability this what we
can get with a with the associative
processing so here the point here that
in in in CPU in in CPU we send we send
others to the memory and in place
computing in APU with we search by
content in CPU fetch the data from the
memory and we mark the data in place so
we can mark the data and do the
operation only
two-bit line which we already mark we we
compute severally PACA we compute
everything everything in place so this
is the this is a different now let's
look a little bit about architecture
internally there are many many banks in
many sections and every bit line every
bit line I can do some nor own end
operation if you return back to our to
our a car notable example here here we
want to implement this to an end and
suppose we have this data here and and
and we can implement in every section
this min term in this min term because
it has disconnected so this is bit line
actually it is 24 24 rolls in every
section in the chip now we are switch
those two section together and and
connect the nor between the to read and
get then a Norlin and get the final
result and then disconnected and
continue this is the way how how it work
if you want to do some neighborhood
operation who have the ability to ship
this right to the left
connect/disconnect so we have all this
ability in the memory so actually with
the readwrite operation and with the
multi section is switches left right so
we built a library that support we have
no limitation which function to do okay
so this is a retoucher has many call it
MLB mm logic block memory logic because
we convert memory to logic and this is
this is like the layout where the layout
of the chip so if we compare this layout
to to to standard layout of GTB TV what
we see here here we have in gpgpu there
is a block that dedicated to floating
point 64 blocks are dedicated
to 232 every function every function has
different block here it's a it's it's
it's based on a memorable it's
multifunction here for example here we
can sometimes do floating-point
sometimes we want to do softmax
sometimes we want to do it okay so it's
fully programmable we don't lose if for
example this guy here we don't want to
do floating-point 64 so all this area is
not useful it's not useful here's all
the area everything is working all the
time to run our algorithm and of course
the power is much lower because we don't
bring data to external memory just at
the beginning with a chunk the data and
we do most of the computation inside the
memory let's now look on some some some
example example applications okay okay
this is a table top of the KD K nearest
neighbor K nearest neighbor here we have
in this example we have a s 3 groups
called the trailing green and blue a
divided two-dimensional here x and y and
and we have a new items coming in and
you want to decided to classify to which
groups its belong so what can use member
say that for example k equal 4 find the
finds a for finds the four nearest
neighbor of that and give me the
majority the majority is green in this
case so it's it it is it is a green so
but but in real life will not have only
a few product we have
billion of products and dimension is not
2x my dimension K be 100 feature 200
feature can be can be very big and K is
not 3 sometimes want to find K equal
10,000 so it's this problem is cannot be
implemented in GPGPU and in services so
it's take it can be implemented but it's
tech times takes hours thanks thanks
here he will have the sauce ative memory
we just we define ok this is a bit line
ok we have 100 feature each feature is
16-bit 16-bit by by 100 is 1.6 kept it
ok
each we define every bit line 1.6 1.6 k
bit and we dump them to get in the
memory then we have a query we are we
just we open the right enable and we are
in 1 o'clock that it took o 0 & 1 we
distribute the date we distribute the
query in all the memory in 2 o'clock not
1 by 1 in 2 o'clock with the stability
query then we want to do operations we
don't two-bit line with the norm and
operation with the logic as I show you
before so so what would you here is here
we want to do some cosine similarity
cosine similarity is a dot product and
add and it's always a dot product
between between the two vectors and and
there are some some some normal little
normalization so this is cosine I can do
hemming search any any type any type of
that everything is memory then I show
you the next slide I found the top KEK
in associative computing we can compute
top K is this is the owner literature
that they can compute the top K in all
of one complexity this means that if we
have 1 billion number and a 1 I want to
find the top 10,000 its
Texas sometimes to find the top ten top
billion NOK top three any number same
time all of one I will show you maybe
you start thinking how we can do that
justice I hope I open your mind now
maybe you can imagine how we do that and
then we we found the majority and and
get the data which is more than 1000 X
improvement to any other architecture
and of course it's very easily in the
memory this function already will run in
our chip run under tens of flow we
already support tens of float top came
running which run necessity now let's
see how we can compute top K in
associative way okay we start with the
most significant bit the bit lines going
now horizontal we start with the most
significant bit suppose we have let's
say millions and we looked on the
associative we can look on bits lines as
much as we want so we looked on to all
the more significant bit and say okay if
there's some which are zero
I'm not candidate to be max only I
looked on the one and then continue so I
start and this is al worden I start with
I define here a mask mask me that all
our candidate to be the top K all our
candidate now went before I start for me
everybody can be the top K V is exact
count that in in the progress here the
exact number of every if whatever if we
have one here it will belong to the top
K now nothing is belong to the top K and
now everything nothing is we don't talk
about but everyone now is a candidate
this is
candidate and this is the route rooftop
cake so we start with the most
significant bit as you see here we are a
write another vector again in the memory
the inverse of the data and and do end
with a mask because we want to know to
whom to whom - to whom - discuss will
then we are with V movies right now zero
and then we count the number of of this
register which is all done in parallel
and we got eleven and for example we
want k equal four with its greater than
than what we want so then we then we go
we break it to the mark and now continue
and down continue to the next bit do it
again until by the end of the day we get
we get so the complexity depend on the
bit slice it's all of the number of of
of the precision it's all funny because
it doesn't matter what is the size a of
the record so actually we get off one
complexity of top of top K it's very
very very important to application like
a recommendation and deep learning many
people using using the top cake until
now people it was hard to implement so
people try to find another direction how
to implement some algorithm but this
gives the ability to do top cake in real
time in microsecond level not in second
so and it actually works and this is a
topic so if I have an ability to do top
K very efficiently I can maybe I looked
on a on recognition for example if I
have if I have an image or if I have a
text or if I have a voice
I can convert any such signal to feature
for example image I can generate feature
by the convolutional layer convolution
layered generated feature not talking
about the up to the fully connected if I
run the convolution layer again I again
the feature of the image if I take a
text I do some award embedding etc to
general generic feature so if I have if
I if I can generate the future and if I
have a memory that can do compute I can
put all these features in the memory and
then when they're coming in another
signal such as another image I take his
feature and I I do the processing in
real-time inside the associative array
to find to find a similarity okay
another example is sparse matrix
multiplication as we know there is a
very very it's a problem to do a sparse
matrix multiplication because there is a
lot of dependencies in is a sparse a lot
of dispenses because it needs a key
value search a lot of dependencies so
actually in GPGPU because they are wrong
to push everything to vector
multiplication they do something like a
SVD so they break is a sparse to small
small matrix by by a the SVD and they do
the matrix multiplication but here we
can do the matte accumulation but here
we can also do the exact the matter to
obsession of real sparse matrix how we
do that this is example show for example
dense dense vector by is pass by sparse
matrix here here is here is a spouse as
you can see here there is a lot of 0 and
I represent this matrices it can be 1
million by 1 million or more I represent
this path by by a table by indices let's
say the value number three is its column
number one a row number two the value of
five it's a column number two
and Rhonda mercy it's a story etc so the
number of item here is a number of the
nonzero element in the spouse in the
sparse matrix so what we do here we we
said okay now this row is 0 so we're not
talking about we say okay this we okay
we say okay search all columns equal
whole number 2 - 0 number 2 I'm looking
all column which is although which is
equal to there's only one here do search
do exact search and then - all of them I
write the value minus 2 now I search a
column number 3 I search a column number
4 here I find here and here
so I write for them together - one
mistake clock doesn't matter if they won
or many which states take one o'clock
once the data in the memory so I use the
function of a exact search the function
of come a ability of the associative
memory to bring the Delta to bring the
data by indices so the complexities of
course is depend of the non zero element
and then I do the multiply
multiplication in parallel and then I
get the result which as you can see here
this is a complexity a sparse by spouse
multiplication even there is no it's so
complicated isn't it's not this function
even is not supporting in terms of law
but we're going to write our function to
tezo flow that supports pass with sparse
matrix multiplication so here we have
two table we have two to multiply two
indices table and to get third table
here so so this is presentation of the
first step of the second table so
actually the same with we get the first
day candidate a call it the road number
one and then we search in and then we
mark over them and here we do the same
as what we show before
then after few iteration we got we got
is a output the output is the output
result here so the complexity here as
you can see here is off beta plus log
beta which which beta is a non zero
element so as long as we have more and
more nonzero element there is more
efficiency to do it in a subset if it
doesn't matter if the size of the matrix
is 1 billion by 1 billion it's only
depend on the non zero element a compare
this ISM this is the best as they a
gpgpu God which is depend of n square as
it try not on and third and square plus
is plus plus which is more than 1000
improvement but it's depend on the size
of n the number of for you it's my cocoa
python and of course things of law we
support we support 10 to 1 which is a
programming model of that but if there's
some people student whatever PhD that
once you understand how to write an
associative of course there is a lot of
room for new researchers they can
contact us and we'll be more than happy
to assist okay soft max soft max is very
useful today
in in natural language processing for
example to predict the next role of if I
have if I have a sentence in high ion I
need to some some attention because it
give us probabilities so soft max is
very very important and this is a
function a unfortunately it's very hard
to implement it when when the number of
the items is big because we need to do a
dot product of a of millions of numbers
sometimes we have non linearity function
we have exponent we have a we have
dependencies because we have if you
if you sell the function of the softmax
is is exponent by divided with the sum
of all the exponent of all the database
so I cannot continue to the next step
until I find the exponent or all the
data so supposed to have one mean where
do you store them and if they e if its
exponent is big its overflow some time
is more than 32 bit that there is more
than 64 it's very hard to implement it
so you can hear you need an associative
memory associative array to solve this
this data so dynamic range what is
exponent if the number 20 a 32 bit
floating is not enough even 64 in
associative you can define sometimes if
for specific application I need floating
point with mantissa which is 200 and
exponent is 50 I can divide it easily
for specific application and go back so
I have no limitation on how to define it
it's not that hot precision double
precision single precision it's not
exist here it's not exist I can define
any precision I need to get the best
performance
okay turn off various AGP GPU and the
CPU use teller servers unfortunately to
get we already checked it to get a
accuracy you need at least 20
coefficients at least 20 coefficients so
let's count how many multiplications and
16 date is not enough 32 bit sometimes
even though even 64 it's terrible here I
want to talk about to remove this slide
because its proprietary we have a way
how to do it very very efficiently very
efficiently which is which is out of
magnitude faster and we have almost
close to zero a 100 percent accuracy in
more than 99 point
accuracy but we can go to 100 accuracy
if we increase the precision so we have
very efficient way how to do how to do
they say soft mark so there's no no
limitation now we can do software we can
do top cap you can do now let's see NLP
NLP is a hot day application today let's
see how we do we do a ok how we do NLP
NLP for pushing and answering you know
this is an example of question and
answering for example I have I have a
question answering problem for example
then put dog in the car then I have a
very very long story
and then my Mike took stance car
long story and he drove to San Francisco
and I asked question where is the book
now so I have to it I cannot use simple
a RNN because I need the memory need a
big memory a big memory to pay attention
to or it which happen is a story another
example for language translation this is
from case of the second example the cow
ate the head because it was delicious
all because it was hungry it I want to
translate this from Lily into French
from support there's two meanings to say
eat they eat it is to the cow or it be
because of it because it was delicious
so we need to do attention we have to
looked on all the data keep it in memory
and and and do some soft marks a
function many many algorithm right one
of them is is okay now okay story okay
let's see how we how we do it how it
worked in the sauce ative we input the
data there is some encoder we input the
data data may be sentence my Kaito in
the bottom sentence so I use encoder to
convert it to features
you should remember I show you the
future how we take feature and put in
Vince Fontaine and something to commit
to feature using neural network to
convert the future there is some way to
convert text to feature which is which
is Ward embedding for example or you
know I get a feature vector and
embedding in to the associative memory
processor embedding this feature like
all other features of all the sentence
all the book maybe all the Wikipedia can
be Caesar now I have a bit but I call it
the key now I worry I have the feature
vector what they do here I do dot
product get the result compute softmax
everything in the memory it softmax
everything with read and write operation
again read and write operation the basic
instructions so if you looked on the
atomic function it's written right
operation again then I have to multiply
this of max by that by a value and I can
get okay
I can get the attention attention is it
is a vertical a whiting I didn't explain
to you how we do vertical computing it's
also very efficient to do vertical it's
it's two details to explain everything
right now but we can do the vertical we
can do approach in this direction and in
this version so we do the vertical
operation and get and get this attention
and coming back this one rice called the
Yunnan developed by a by a Western I
think most of you are familiar with that
a his network is you can till you you
take this your sentence
embedding using RNN and and convert use
here softbox and multiply multiply the
softbox by a value gets a tension and go
back back and forth and here you input
the query the same
so this function required softmax
require a dot product multiplication top
K everything is here so here how would
implement of course key values of marks
all of this is in the associative array
can be done very easily we are going to
demonstrate this in our chip this one of
our demonstration to show and to end
with Bobby a with Bobby text we're going
to show how it work here again sort of
magnitude okay now let's see another hot
direction in in deep learning is low
shot I'm not going to show how we do
CNN convolution neural network because
this is many many good solution for that
so I'm focusing on things which are hot
today which cannot be achieved since
this is again multiplication we can put
the coefficients in memory but I'm not
talking I'm just talking about things
which are very exciting now in deep
learning which call it low short one
short learning what is the problem with
a one-shot today guarded based
optimization today we know it is a very
impressive result today and for but it
was good for for image classification
but this is what a lot a lot of data a
to learn and also in the database for
example we need to put 5,000 different
on cat 5,000 different of dog 5,000
different a cow I want to put only two
dog took how three people two chairs
this is this is a notion associative
computing is that a human because in our
human body brain people when we take a
child you not show him 10,000 different
on dogs and say this is a dog you teach
him that is a dog and say okay this dog
anything that is the cat next time you
show him a courtesy okay this is dog and
this is the cat so so why how
pollution neural networks working today
is good for image batteries it's more
academic it's not practice because you
need so much data so much data to do
that let's see how we do it in
associative just show you the simple way
but not going to send everything now we
go to show a zero shot and fusion now
let's say I take with zero shot I said I
take a system that already trained for
example i take v GG i take the v GG
already trained to all the database all
the image that already trained a heavy v
DG for me it doesn't matter now if I
input different images that what I teach
for me the convolutional layer it's a
it's it's a feature generators it's a
speech of generator generator features I
bet fit another image and get the
feature
get the feature map it doesn't matter
with the dog I don't know what is a
feature it takes the image let's say to
2008 to 2010 elect features this feature
represent what I level to it in one case
it can be cow one case it can be pencil
one casing can be chair but it's a rich
feature i embedded into to the feature
inside and the next time won't have
another dog I do some cosine similarity
and find the top K and get which is the
most grosser and second a second in and
and continue so this is one way second
way is ah okay this is dimension
reduction because in the convolution
layer I want to get the feature I know
to put feature in the associative array
so in if I looked on the convolution
layer of VG for example the final state
of the convolution layer I have five I
have seven by seven by 512 which is
20,000
I don't want to put
twenty thousand each vector I want to
reduce this feature so I do some
algorithm to reduce to reduce the
features to reduce the dimension is the
input is twenty thousand the auto take
for example a two hundred the way how
it's wrong I teach this matrix by if I
have two similarity between two vectors
mm I want the same similarity of a
vector of two hundred this is a cost
function so i generate i do this so this
is this way I reduce the feature and I'm
bending it into the associative memory
no shot no shot in the in the one shot
we use already friend and trained data
with the low shot it's well it will not
start with it with pro train we train
the data but in different way we change
the date in the way that where for
example vgg but we can put it even a
very simple network but we teach the
system that that we want a similarity
between we want to keep similar value
between click between key that will be
closed if the clause we want the error
will be minimum is a far if it's not
close I want that the arrow will be will
be a far away so I I do the learning
based on similarity search between two
values and do the back propagation and
this oriented to cosine similarity
similarity approach actually we do that
with a successful on the Omni God only
got a characters we got in a few short
between one to four more than 99% of say
affair of accuracy when with the
strength data based on similarity search
instead of standard Gandhian
okay a programming model very simple
people rides their application
tensorflow on standard CPU okay the
output is the tender flow graph is is
written to the device memory of the card
and here the APU chip manipulate this
graphic dependencies an executive
function so this way we program so you
write in standard a CPU right turns of
law genetic execution graph download to
the memory its Excel it's not
associative memory to another memory
DRAM and then we have inside the chip I
didn't explain it inside the chip here
we have for arc poor processor to take
care about that that to control to
control the chip okay we are developing
okay now we are in stage in less than
two months we are tapping out the chip
we are working on it more than two years
or tapping out in two months
and we're going to have a valuation
board in around the Royal Mail that will
have four chips that it can be used for
testing to to evaluate the performance
the performance of the card aid we have
in every chip where for APU chip every
chip have two million two million
processors two million bit lines so with
eight millions we get between we get 8
beta boolean operations 8 Peter Williams
operation 6.4 tenth of this is for
floating-point but for our other we as a
pic photons 8 beta internal because the
computer memory we have to pet a bit per
second internal ion and we also have
here some Durant form is memory device
and tens of law
tens of law
support okay this is a current product
but we looked on the future let's see
how far we can go with this technology
this technology today it's work we
convert SRAM to compute but if you
looked on the non-volatile memory which
has very big bigger of tens of beginners
is very low dense see how they look then
they also have itself they also have a
bit line and I can program them to do
the neurone end but on selective on
unselective just bit line so the
non-volatile memory in the future can do
associative computing so we can do
computing on this on the storage not on
the memory on the storage in the future
so this is how how how it goes
so if we looked on this map today we
have how this flash DRAM L 1 l 2 3 and
cpu registers file this is same memory
here we put all this type of associative
computing based on endurance here we
have three ROM based as you can see here
he would have rerun bay is a PC ROM
there are many types of non-volatile
memory
this is busy with with this is this
flash we can do processing flash versus
flashes if there is endurance problem we
cannot write more than 100,000 times so
if I want to do some operation unless at
the second eye eye I destroy it so it
cannot be but they can do some search
more not just not read not write just
write
Iram has a better as a better
performance in endurance and every time
every step which I go here and go him
with endurance here hidden joins better
he knows better and in Estoril with no a
nine yards we are here right now we are
here
beginning 2000
Dean we convert estarán to associative
very poor so we are here that stt rom
has also very good endurance so we
believe that in five years six years now
we can convert we can convert the
resistant ROM to do to compute base and
our approach our patterns we can do that
okay this is this summary as you can see
here we can do off one met top K
similarity search it's a try etcetera
it's fully programmable see it's more
programmable than the standard CPU or
GPU because I have more capability I
don't have building blocks that as
floating point fixed point it's it said
its processor associative processor
based on memory technology so I have a
lot a lot of flexibility and extending
more slow and and leveraging advanced
memory technology growth so we are
following this to pattern the better of
Muslim and in memory and memory
technology a ok so this is a last slide
if there are some student Master PhDs
that want to collaborate to do some PhD
project research we'll be more than
happy to help assist to they can contact
us ok thank you very much
[Applause]
you